this is not conventional hypocrisy
this is let's stop lying an act of
hostility
against the population of the country
they despise you
they're flaunting it this is how people
who don't like you
behave they force you to do one thing
they do another they get caught they're
not embarrassed and they keep forcing
you to
to do the thing they're not doing tucker
carlson ripping into politicians who
don't follow their own coronavirus
restrictions like california governor
gavin newsom who was caught attending a
birthday party wearing no mask
and not socially distance but he's not
the only elected official caught bending
the rules as the public suffers
philadelphia mayor jim kenney was seen
at a bar
just before announcing a ban on all
indoor dining d.c
mayor muriel bowser traveled to delaware
to attend joe biden's victory speech
ignoring her own travel restrictions she
says it was
essential travel and chicago mayor lori
lightfoot attended a massive street
party
less than 24 hours after she announced a
stay-at-home advisory
for the entire city with us now governor
mike huckabee governor it's always good
to see you and the reason this gavin
newsom thing is getting so much
attention is because
he didn't just break the rules he blew
up the rules we mentioned that it was
a large gathering more than a dozen
people right no social distancing
no masks and they said it was outdoors
but it was actually
indoors because they had to close the
sliding glass doors because it was so
loud
and the cdc repeatedly says loud events
where all you've got you know the the
droplets are coming out of your mouth
can be super spreader events this thing
broke every rule you can have
well i think you're being a little harsh
on him trace because i mean he didn't
sing he didn't chant and he didn't
worship
those things would have been dangerous
but simply going and not wearing a mask
and
yelling with his friends that's okay
look he
is phonier than a vegan at a steakhouse
and he just proved it and that video
just undid him but there's a fix to all
this whether it's lori lightfoot or
newsome
or the mayor of dc a simple fix
if you're a government official and you
shut other people's businesses down
you don't get paid because if they lose
their paycheck and you're
the one responsible you don't get your
paycheck let's see how that goes
i'm not being facetious about it there's
no
skin in the game of these government
officials they're making
big decisions about the peasants like us
who have to live by their rules but they
don't live by them and they have no
consequence they don't lose a dime of
their salary
they get taxpayer money and it never
goes away
let that go away let them suffer some
consequences financially
you're going to see this change you talk
about peasants and you know you've got a
california committee woman she's a
republican harmeet dillon she said
follow
quoting here eating with a bunch of
lobbyists at an expensive restaurant
this is at the same time that you put
half of california out of work
add up drinks and appetizers their meal
per person was more
than the monthly unemployment check and
of course people don't know
the french laundry average average tab
about a thousand bucks
yeah this is not a place where people
get their clothes
cleaned their wallets are cleaned out
because it's that expensive the average
minimum dine uh dining experience
is 350 per person minimum
now think about how many people could
even conceive of spending that for a
meal
you've got california legislators going
out to hawaii
this is the hypocrisy and they need to
read the stories of the bolshevik
revolution and marie antoinette and find
out what happens when the peasants
get it up to here with that kind of
stuff by the way you get i think you get
water and a toothpick for 350 at the
french laundry governor i just i don't
know that for sure but i think that's
about the size of it
you talk about the lawmakers going to
hawaii i want to put this up on the
screen because you have these excuses
right assembly member
jordan cunningham on the trip to hawaii
said the following here
in this event promotes intelligent
public policy in our state in fact
we are here discussing ways we can
safely reopen our society
and save our small businesses workers
and kids
yeah no better no better place to to
work on coronavirus than the fairmont
wailea it's amazing because muriel
bowser says oh the trip was essential
you have the philadelphia mayor saying
well
the restaurant really wasn't in
pennsylvania proper
the excuses are almost as annoying as
the actual acts themselves your final
thoughts
they truly are you know to be in an
airplane for eight hours in a small
aluminum tube that's perfectly safe to
get to hawaii
uh yeah that's fine i'm sure all the
little people all the little people
understand how valuable it was to them
for their public officials on the
taxpayers dime
to go to hawaii and back when they can't
even go to church
or go and have thanksgiving with their
own families
sure that makes sense governor mike
huckabee always good to hear you sir
thank you
thank you trace